fin del suspenso Después de varios meses
en un discurso a la nación el presidente
senegalés sorprendió con este anuncio
nuestra compasión queridos compatriotas
más decisión mi decisión larga y
seriamente pensada
es no ser candidato en las próximas
elecciones del 25 de febrero de 2024
incluso así la Constitución me ve el
derecho y la Constitución
tras llegar al poder en 2012 hizo
modificar la constitución en 2016 para
limitar a dos el número de mandatos
presidenciales fue reelegido en 2019
según el jefe del Estado esta reforma
ponía los contadores de su tiempo en la
presidencia en cero lo que le daba
posibilidad de un tercer mandato su
sorpresiva renuncia a la reelección
debería calmar un clima extremadamente
tenso que ha vivido el país en las
últimas semanas pero los senegaleses se
preguntan Quién sucederá maquisal
necesitamos un presidente que se apiada
de los senegaleses necesitamos un
presidente que no mate a su pueblo
necesitamos un presidente que escuche a
su pueblo
la candidatura de Guzmán soncó su
adversario número uno sigue en duda
absuelto en un caso de vio fue sin
embargo condenado el mes pasado a dos
años de cárcel por corrupción de menores
un complot y persecución según sus
partidarios
tras el juicio y El veredicto cientos de
personas salieron a la calle lo que
provocó los disturbios más graves en el
país desde hace años la violencia costó
la vida a 16 personas según las
autoridades y a 30 según la oposición